and so now we've come to what maybe we
can call our third period in this
afternoon
Michael W young is a professor at
Rockefeller University he is a biologist
and a geneticist he earned his
undergraduate degree as we heard in
biology from the University of Texas at
Austin in 1971 after a summer of
research with Burke Judd and probably
this emphasizes the importance of summer
internships he was working with a
Drosophila genome and that probably
spurred on his interest in science
because he remained at the University of
Texas to complete a PhD in genetics in
1975 Michael Young continued his studies
throughout his postdoctoral training at
Stanford University's School of Medicine
with an interest in molecular genetics
where he worked in Dave Hogg mrs. lab
from 1978 he's been on the faculty of
Rockefeller University in New York in
2004 Mike young was appointed vice
president for academic affairs at
Rockefeller University and he was also
granted the Richard and gene Fisher
chair Michael Young is a member of the
US National Academy of Sciences and his
research has shown how interactions
among certain genes and their proteins
produce molecular oscillations at the
level of individual cells I would like
to ask all of you in joining me to
welcome Mike Young up to the podium to
deliver his Nobel lecture entitled time
travels a 40 year journey from Joseph
Ellis clock mutants to human circadian
disorders
[Applause]
ah bright lights it's wonderful to be
here so I guess I
I'm the caboose I'll pull us along and
fill in a few gaps and tell you about
some more recent work that's been on
this remarkable journey let me start by
just Jeff had talked about rhythms being
all around us and I think this is an
example my wife were out on and I were
out on a hike a few summers ago in New
Mexico and we came across this whoops
came across this plant which is called
the Colorado four o'clock and what I
want you to notice is that all the
blooms are closed and notice this this
little branch here just so you know I'm
I'm not I'm playing straight this is it
two o'clock when we're going out on the
hike two hours later or a few hours
later we come back and we see this at 6
p.m. so this remarkable plant rhythm is
believed to be due to the behavior of
the pollinator hokhmah which is active
at night in the evenings and of course
you're in a desert environment that's
arid water is precious and it takes
water pumped into the petals of those
leaves to open them up so this appears
to be a strategy it seems to conserve
water in an arid environment and have
those blooms available for pollination
at times that makes sense with regard to
the behavior of your pollinator another
example of these rhythms that are all
around us is this record of hamster
behavior that appeared in a symposium
volume in 1960 this is each each line is
a is a 24-hour interval so you're
looking at 25 days in this animals life
in
complete darkness the whole time and it
still amazes me when the animal gets on
its running wheel you get these
deflections from that line and you can
you can predict within a couple of
minutes each day when the animal is
going to get on the running wheel and
when it's going to get off and you'll
notice another feature of this is it's
not 24 hours it's about 24 hours it's
circadian which you know how could it be
anything other than an internal
reflection of some kind of an internal
pacemaker as Michael pointed out we have
still other phenotypes as we acquire new
tools to look more deeply for red Missa
tee
these are rhythms that are established
in the head of the fruit fly this was of
Drosophila this was work of Adam Clara
Chang and Herman V Ninh about 1516 years
ago using microarray data and the way
you read this is that this is 150 gene
pattern stacked one on top of the other
each row of red and green boxes is the
pattern of a single gene followed over
six 24-hour intervals some with a light
dark cycle but others complete darkness
and they're stacked according to time of
day of their maximum expression so so
these would be expressed maximally at
dawn at noon these at dusk these at
midnight and so forth and I think what I
hope you see are red and green stripes
running top to bottom just illustrating
these waves of expression over this very
large group of genes and the other thing
I'd like to point out is that those are
not vertical stripes they're they're
running diagonally across the chart
which is pointing out for us that this
timer is not simply swinging back and
forth between two states day and night
it's a program that generates patterns
of gene expression where every hour of
the day there's a unique relationship
between genes that are hitting their
peaks and genes that are hitting their
lows the next slide shows that same
pattern but now next to it our results
that are obtained with three clock
mutants period timeless and clock so
those are no mutants and where are the
stripes the stripes are now gone and as
Michael pointed out in his talk a few
minutes ago what we appreciate is that
not only does the behavior go away with
these mutants but all of the genetic
changes that are programmed these this
temporal program is eliminated by loss
of those genes and this is unique to the
genes that contribute to this pacemaker
mechanism that we've been studying so
just to give you an overview once again
of the way this pacemaker works we have
the period and timeless genes on
different chromosomes in the nucleus
transcripts are produced by Association
of clock and cycle activating
transcription of both per and timeless
their RNAs are translated in the
cytoplasm to give timeless and period
proteins but then we run into some post
transcriptional breaks on the system
that produced the oscillations that we
see one of the important initial breaks
is produced by a gene we called double
time that's turned out when cloned in
sequence to be casein kinase 1 and that
kinase phosphorylates the period protein
and marks it for destruction so at the
early stage of each daily cycle when
period proteins and timeless proteins
are at very low levels double time which
is constitutively produced at high
levels at all times of day and night is
the first partner that the period
protein sees and so most of the early
period proteins that are produced
are immediately dispensed with in the
cell on the other on the other hand many
hours later as timeless proteins build
up as we have iron higher levels of
timeless proteins we now can produce
something new which is a period timeless
dimer and period timeless dimers are
immune to this phosphorylation based
destruction by double time and they also
have a property that they now seek the
nucleus whereas period and timeless on
their own seek the cytoplasm and of
course as you've already heard period
and timeless are inhibitors they bind to
physically clock and cycle and repress
the action of those activators to close
this cycle in a light dark cycle that
would all happen in constant darkness
which is why we see oscillations
principally in constant darkness but in
day/night cycles we also have the issue
of the these clocks following the phase
of the environmental cycle and that's
achieved in the fly by a protein called
cryptochrome which is a fotolia's like
molecule that absorbs light when it
absorbs light it physically associates
with timeless recruits proteins that
will cause both timeless and
cryptochrome to become phosphorylated
and degraded so that all day long when
the Sun is up
we have no timeless because of the
activation of cryptochrome and of course
if you have no timeless all the period
protein will only have one partner which
is double time which means we also have
no period so we have massive amounts of
RNA for both period and timeless during
the day time but it's sterile in the
sense that we're not accumulating
protein until the Sun Goes Down and this
is essentially how the phase of the of
this clock is established and as we move
a fly from New York to Stockholm for
example you can see the effects that
would be expected from this kind of a
mechanism so the as as Michael pointed
out
there is a great deal of homology when
we move from the fly to other animals
the rest of the animal kingdom so in US
for example we have many familiar
proteins we have a clock and beam out
which are the orthologs of clock and
cycle in the fly we have three period
proteins / 1 / 2 + / 3 all of which are
related to the single period protein
that we have in the fly we also once
again have casein kinase 1 the double
time ortholog in mammals which once
again controls the accumulation and fate
of the period protein 1 difference an
important difference we have is whereas
cryptochrome was a partner for timeless
controlling its accumulation
now cryptochrome has become the partner
for / which is a an interesting
evolutionary switch in dance partners
but it's it's a cryptochrome / dimer
instead of a timeless / dimer that now
moves to nuclei and inhibits the action
of clock and b-mail and I'll come back
to these differences in a few moments
when I begin to speak more about human
clocks so originally the discovery that
clocks were found all over the body was
a discovery and flies it was made in
drosophila by jeff hall in collaboration
with steve k in 1997 and they had
generated a form of / which was
connected to Lucifer rays so that you
could use a light monitoring scheme to
to image live Drosophila and all that
the the intact and and dissected body
parts of the fly and realized that there
were / driven cycles all over all over
the fly and as Michael pointed out we
now know that much the same is true for
mammals including ourselves
and in this example I'm just giving you
examples of clocks that are found in the
brain versus the lung the liver and
skeletal muscle and I want to suggest
some of the things that might happen to
you if you move from New York to
Stockholm or even when you impose a
brain body conflict experimentally in
the lab that can be studied continuously
for many many days so if if this mouse
is kept on New York City time it's a
nocturnal animal it's going to be active
at night it's going to be sleeping
during the day if unperturbed it will
want to eat at night when it's active
and be quiescent during the day and we
we have these clocks in different
tissues all agreeing on the time zone
they're all agreeing that they're
working together on New York City time
many years ago Michael menaker at the
University of Virginia did an experiment
in which he established a brain body
conflict by allowing the mouse to eat
only in the middle of the day when it
should be in the middle of its sleep
interval provide food for an hour or so
after a few days the animal learns to
predict will wake up spontaneously
before the food is delivered eat the
food go back to sleep but then get on
its running wheel and run on the wheel
all night as it would appropriately for
New York City what was found after a few
days of this though is that the clocks
everywhere except the brain had changed
their phases by this new routine so the
the brain is still stuck in New York
it's seeing that light-dark cycle it's
producing those activity rhythms that
are appropriate at night but the rest of
the body is in disagreement is not
pulled along by what the brain thinks is
going on they're getting their cues
directly from the feeding schedule or
from other organs organs in the animal
that are responding directly from the
feeding schedule so we have in effect an
animal that who's a collection of clocks
that can't agree with one another and
this is remarkably similar to what
happens when we undergo jetlag different
organs proceed to the new time zone at
different paces we're very much this is
very much a problem of a multiplicity of
clocks that can't agree for several days
when we change time zones dramatically
in this fashion what we do know from
these kinds of experiments is if the
animal is maintained for many days or
even weeks we begin to see a number of
anomalous events in metabolism and
behavior that are consistent with much
more severe effects that come from
actually eliminating clocks in these
different subsets of organs so let me
turn now to some studies that we've been
doing in humans that consider a related
problem which is what if your clock
doesn't agree with the environmental
cycle we've got a 24-hour environmental
cycle what if you're genetically
programmed to have a clock as we've
heard in flies like a first short or a
purl on what happens if we have a clock
that's out of sync with the with the
turning of the earth and I'm going to be
talking about a syndrome called delayed
sleep phase disorder we can think of
individuals that have this disorder as
night owls extreme night owls so they
might be hammering away on their
keyboards late at night getting a big
burst of energy off of their computer
screen which is if anything going to
make things worse for them late into the
night and these are some of the
after buttes of these individuals we
think this this appears to affect about
5% of the population from clinical
studies it's a persistent delay in the
timing of the major sleep episode and
strong resistance to efforts to try to
manipulate sleep phase to advance it to
make it easier to show up for work at
eight or nine o'clock in the morning for
example
so these are records from two
individuals that were in a study we
began a number of years ago on the left
is a control subject which we'll call
tau 18 and these are activity records
wake-sleep records then involve two
kinds of monitoring one is with a
wristwatch like activity monitor and the
other is just with entries in a sleep
log that's kept by the bed so that each
day or evening when the end of a
individual gets into bed they marked the
time down and when they get out of bed
they put another mark in the log so we
have two correlated pieces of data to
consider so the the the way the data are
plotted here is to plot not just 24
hours but 48 hour intervals in this
process and what this allows us to do is
compare the time that each end that the
individual is getting into bed with the
time that the individual is getting out
of bed so you notice in the control
subject from both the sleep log and the
activity graphs that there's a very neat
and consistent pattern in which at about
11:30 to midnight this individual is
getting in bed each night and rapidly
thereafter going to sleep and at 7 or 8
each morning again pretty consistently
they've become active and they put a
mark in the sleep log that they're
getting out of bed
the dspd subjects town 11 has a quite an
erratic record by comparison but I think
the most important features are if we
look at the in bed times versus the out
of bed times we see that this is an
individual that's always getting in bed
well after midnight and the out of bed
times they're getting there they're
there they're becoming active again
usually just a little bit before noon so
this is a striking phase variation with
regard to the timing event of their wake
sleep cycle so we were able to study
that end
and several members of the family and
did a a whole exome sequencing of all of
these members of the extended family and
we found that there were a number of
those indicated in black or gray that
had an aberrant pattern of sleep and one
cousin over here with a normal sleep
pattern and the difference that came up
by whole exome sequencing in these
individuals gave us one most likely
candidate which is a variation at the
gene cryptochrome one this mutation is a
single nucleotide change it's at a
splice donor site just downstream from
exon 11 and that change predicts that
exon 12 will be spliced now directly tax
sign exon 10 skipping the information in
exon 11 so that would predict a 72 base
base is missing in the messenger RNA and
24 amino acids missing from the protein
and here are we had collected dermal
fibroblasts from each of the subjects in
this study there were 20 or so subjects
that we studied and you'll see subject
11 is uniquely producing two forms of
the RNA from cryptochrome one and two
forms of protein in the skin in the in
the dermal fibroblasts so clearly a
significant change in the structure of
both the RNA in the protein in this
individual we went on to ask whether or
not that modified gene was enough to
change the circadian clock of a naive
cultured cell and Alena Pat Kay in our
lab did this by starting with the
cultured cell that had no copy of
cryptochrome usually would have two
copies cryptochrome one and cryptochrome
two if you have no copies you'll have
you'll be
rythmic the cells will be a rhythmic and
she used this as a test system to ask is
there a difference in the pattern of
circadian rhythmicity at the cellular
level given a wild-type form of
cryptochrome one or this variant form of
cryptochrome one and as you see here
there was a very consistent pattern of
rhythmicity that comes from the
wild-type form the full-length form of
cryptochrome and this truncated form
gave a pattern with a longer circadian
rhythm about half an hour longer than
that provided by the wild-type gene so
clearly this gene is capable of
producing a change in the circadian
rhythm of that of of the recipient cells
so once again the difference between the
fly clock over here and the human clock
shown in the right
important new role for cryptochrome so
this is the this of course is the gene
that is now modified in this case
cryptochrome the work it does is in
conjunction with purr to form that
inhibitory complex that suppresses the
activity of clock and cycles so keeping
that in mind Elina went took a look at
the interactions among these proteins we
know from that model from what's known
about the human clock and the fly clock
that period and cryptochrome will be
partners to form an inhibitory complex
that will then further physically
interact with clock and be mal and so
she asked the following question does it
matter with regard to the physical
association among these proteins whether
you're the full-length form of this
protein of the truncated form of the
protein so if I start down here for
example and we have input proteins where
we've created only the full-length
protein is provided or the truncated
form of the protein is provided or a
synthetic heterozygote in which both
forms of the protein are produced what
happens if you now do an imitation
with a target of hemagglutinin
associated clock and what is found is
that the full-length form of
cryptochrome is very weakly recovered
much stronger recovery of the truncated
form and in this synthetic heterozygote
again a strong bias toward the truncated
form of the protein up here on the left
is just a reciprocal experiment where
you're the focus of immune of
precipitation is B mal and again the
inputs are over here and we see much the
same response the full-length protein
has recovered poorly relative to the
robust recovery of the truncated protein
and the synthetic heterozygote is
strongly biased toward the truncated
form of the protein in contrast if we
look at what's happening with
interactions with per itself
how does cryptochrome the how did these
two varieties of cryptochrome interact
with per itself we find here's the input
that the input and they pulled down
looked very much the same so in summary
what is seems to be the case is that a
period in cryptochrome appeared to have
a strong physical interaction that is
not affected by this mutation but the
interaction of the period cryptochrome
heterodimer with its target activator
proteins o'clock and b mal is strongly
altered by this mutation so we thought
all of this was extremely interesting at
the level of molecular biology but we
were really stunned when we sat down at
a computer a few years ago and asked
well how common is this mutation in
human populations and this is a this is
what we we saw when we did that looking
at the exact database available through
Cambridge the overall world population
the the frequency of this allele suggest
that carriers and again this is behaving
as a dominant so far as
we've seen so far carriers would be
almost 1% level in the population if we
focus on Europeans those that are
European or European descent the allele
frequency is shown here so twice that
would be the carrier frequency that's
about one in 75 individuals of European
descent so we were stunned that this
allele which had these features changing
the function of the clock was so
prevalent but it did suggest that we
should be able to identify without a lot
of trouble additional carriers to
confirm this relationship and we set up
a collaboration with typhoon o selec at
Bilkent University in in Turkey who had
been working with a colleague across the
hall
Jeff Friedman and typhoon recognized the
number of families that had carriers
both homozygous and heterozygous
carriers large families only a few of
which are shown here and by looking at
the patterns of sleep in all of these
individuals we're able to to compare the
patterns shown in the filled boxes the
dark boxes carrier boxes versus those in
the unfilled boxes which are non
carriers and we can plot the behaviors
of these two groups as shown here the
non carriers the the shown over here
that have what we call a mid sleep
measurement on free days so on free days
when do you go to sleep when do you wake
up and what's the midpoint of that
interval and for most of us that's going
to be around 4:30 in the morning and
that's true for most of the non carriers
in these families but their relatives
who are carriers whether heterozygous or
homozygous have a very different pattern
that's shifted by about two hours very
much like the original probe and that we
studied where the Midd sleep point is
about the time that most of us would be
getting up and taking off for work the
there's a second phenotype that emerged
which are fragmented sleepers these are
individuals that the that point to their
major sleep episode is a short nap that
can be early or late in the evening
again something not seen in the
non-carriers so to summarize what we've
seen we've got a number of unrelated
families in which the presence of this
variation predicts the SPD the high
frequency the penetrants the high
penetrance of this mutation with regard
to that behavior suggests a significant
contribution to dspd worldwide since the
mutation is found in multiple members of
each family it's running through the
families it's being inherited we have to
assume that every tissue has these
altered clocks the the variation shows
enhanced binding to clock and B mail as
I pointed out and it appears to be a
strengthened transcriptional inhibitor
by other work that I don't have time to
talk about today the competitive binding
to clock and B mail suggests a molecular
basis for the dominance of this trait
and finally as I mentioned it's
sufficient to express just this one gene
in individual cells in culture and
recapitulate an altered circadian rhythm
so lastly I just like to point at some
questions we have for the future one of
the problems in studying sleep disorders
there's been relationships to other
medical conditions it's long been the
case that anecdotally a variety of
metabolic and psychiatric disorders are
often said to be associated with
disordered sleep and very often delayed
sleep
and but it's been difficult or
impossible to establish causal
relationships but what we have here I
believe is a new opportunity if you have
large numbers of subjects that are
available to study we should be able to
test whether a particular sleep mutation
extends to other medical problems and
particularly when the mutation can be
studied as it's traveling through
unrelated families we should be able to
rule out the impact of environment and
and make some clear conclusions about
the relationship of mutations of this
sort to other medical disorders and
lastly let me just point to the work to
the people the AI says Jeff put it in
the lab that have contributed to this
work over the many years in the 1980s
Ted bar jello and Rob Jackson were
involved in the initial mapping and
cloning of the period gene sequencing
identifying the nature of the mutations
that Ron Konopka and Seymour Benzer had
initially found some years before in the
1990s Leslie
amita Jeff lino and Adrian all worked on
the discovery and characterization of
the timeless gene and it's protein
shortly thereafter jeff preiss lino
adrian justin and brian all worked on
the discovery and characterization of
double time whose role i've told you
about and in the 2000s we began to move
into the era of micro arrays and looking
at the larger patterns of gene
expression that are controlled by these
clocks and that was principally driven
by Adam Clara Chang and Herman V Ninh
but still more genes to be discovered
Sebastian Martinek found a role for GS
k3 which is particularly interested
interesting still because of its
sensitivity to common commonly used drug
treatments such as lithium in the 2010
or the last seven years drug and arugula
and Nick stavropoulos of both initiated
studies of a different kind of genetics
that of control of sleep duration the
homeostatic control of sleep which along
with circadian regulation controls the
ultimately controls the pattern and as I
mentioned Elena Potkin has been involved
in every aspect of our our human work
and I'll just show one last slide I want
to point first to lino Saez who was a
member of the laboratory for almost 30
years he was involved in almost
everything that I spoke about today
I mean Oh unfortunately passed away in
2014 but I know he would really love to
have been able to be here
Alina Pat key again has been responsible
for every aspect of the human work she's
had her hands on every part of that
project and she is here and I just want
to thank her personally so thanks for
your attention and after the iron
I would like to extend our gratitude to
the Nobel laureates for their extensive
presentations this afternoon may I ask
the laureates on to the stage for a
round of applause
you